So I just want to quickly also
now just review the whole
process of how scale-invariant
features are computed SIFTs.
First we want to find the orientation,
compute the test orientation for
each keypoint region.
And then we want to actually use
the method to kind of find the keypoints
itself and we use local image
gradients at selected scale, and
rotation to describe
each keypoint region.
Here's an example of
invariant local features.
I mean,
here are two examples of the same car.
So here for example, this region
here is matched to this region here.
It's the same car, but
of course, we notice
this patch is exactly the same even with
orientation and all that kind of stuff.
And it finds others
regions like the similar.
This region here is matched to this.
This part here is matched, well it's
available here but there's no match here
because these two here are either
too small or not visible.
The bigger patch here again,
has the same characteristics on both.
So one of the biggest advantage of SIFT
is that basically image content is
transformed into local
feature coordinates that
are invariant to translation, rotation,
scale, and other imaging parameters.
And therefore allows us to
take two pairs of images with
similar appearances of objects and
stuff like that.
And it starts finding the features that
might have seen and do different things,
and that allows us to do the matching.
And that becomes an important part.
So let's say I have these two images.
First, I can run the whole process
again to detect all the features.
Here it found all the features
in these two images.
This is of course the common regions.
These are two images next to each other.
Now of course, what I basically
after I have found the features,
I want to match them.
So here basically,
it find and matches that these
are similar between these two.
And once I match them,
I can also then register them together.
And if I registered, then I can use
that to align the two images together,
which I'm not actually showing.
I'm just basically showing that
these two features are now
matches between these two images.